[Music]
he was the best part of the holiday
special which isn't saying much
but ever since boba fett stood around
looking cool fans wanted to know more
and as we all know learning more about a
star wars character only makes them
cooler
yep cooler i'm alone
solo
super duper cool i'm a person and my
name is anakin
the book of boba fett
you remember him as the mysterious
bounty hunter with just four lines in
the original trilogy and that was
probably enough because now fans are
getting the show they dreamed of and
then it's literally full of naps
as boba fulfills his destiny and becomes
a fleshy ball that floats in milky water
and when you're not watching an old man
take a bath or talking about taking one
i owe you a nice long soak in the back
to tank when this is done you'll drift
off to sleep during one of his many
soaks because as it turns out boba fett
has to think about his whole life before
he becomes crime lord
flashback to that time boba went out
like an absolute chomp
and solve the mystery of how he survived
the sarlacc pit
he crawled out oh then fill in the
blanks of an entire lifetime of failure
and beatdowns from tuscans
to wookies
to really just whoever
as this bumbling oh gets his friends
killed takes revenge on the wrong people
the one that massacred your tuscan
family and blamed it on a speed bike
gang and fights to protect a city that
also would have killed his saviors if
they had the chance don't worry he fails
at that too
nothing to see here folks move along
just bubba fit protecting your homes and
places of business don't forget to tip
your damn yo
thrill as boba replaces all his dead
friends with new ones who have no choice
but to hang out with him like fennec
shan a cool assassin he has to guilt and
bribe into joining his crew i saved your
life two body hogs who have to be his
friend or die would you be loyal to me
if i were to spare you
and this badass tree gang of
these bad ass kids
i'm sorry are those vespas i i can't i
can't take them seriously so by now if
you're thinking this blows can we watch
something else disney is way ahead of
you as the show hard pivots into the
mandalorian phew catch up with mando
chopping up bounties with a lightsaber
even though he doesn't meet the stat
requirements it gets heavier with each
move tricks out as sweet new hot rod do
you used to fly a razor crest
and makes tiny little shirts for his
little bitty beanie baby oh
then ah even more at the return of baby
yoda who's still so cute he offsets the
bad vibes coming from loop deep faker a
short time for you is a lifetime for
someone else yeah and sure grogu and den
bail on their missions and character
arcs to help out boba but desperate
times call for desperate measures and
who boy does this show need
reinforcements no one respects you
okay ahsoka you're up earlier than we
thought campaign get your blue ass in
here all hands on deck people it's an
after-school special down there this is
a dexter jester level emergency thank
you
manners
i like it we're too late abort
get to learn so much more and understand
so much less about tatooine a planet
luke once assured us was very boring but
since there's a wild metropolis full of
space ports casinos and teenage cyborgs
five minutes from beggar's canyon
now it just seems like luke wanted to
join the empire i want to transmit my
application to the academy this year
it's here in the most remote corner of
the center of the galaxy where boba will
become the daimyo a mob boss like jabba
the hutt except this crime lord won't
accept protection money yes or no
tribute or kill people shall i kill them
no
or rough them up i do not torture or
steal things we stole it that's a crime
or demand a meeting
don't you think
do you want the appointment or not and
he definitely says no to drugs there's a
lot of credits to be made from that
orange powder spice is killing our
people even though he had his whole life
changed from chasing brain dust with a
nose lizard
you know i'm starting to think a crime
story on the children's network was a
bad idea i went to the stock market
today i did a business
so break out your slang protocol droid
oh he's singing like a young smooth
there's a gunk stomp jack if that's not
the quack to calling the stiffling slimy
and slip into a nice warm bath until we
get a proper third season of the
mandalorian because this show is 50
dramatic entrance
[Music]
what an entrance and that other 50
you guessed it space meetings do you
have an
[Music]
one of your appointment seeks an
audience with you
do they have an appointment
please come in have a seat arrange a
meeting with the mayor i won't ever meet
him i'm here to make a proposal that's
mutually beneficial
[Music]
starring
stop trying to make fit happen
i like shane she's soft and smooth and
helpful and she kills everyone veeper
groundhog day that's where you know this
guy from we gave a wookie brass knuckles
and got him drunk you'll totally believe
what happened next
princess vespa
irobot that'll do pigs that'll do i whip
my tails back and forth i put my tails
back and forth what beat boobs in the
shadows my child is an honor student at
skywalker jedi academy the dropout you
don't have to be lonely at jawasonly.com
timothy olly fan timothy elephant cadbad
machete in
space
and twins
i find your smooth face disturbing
and if you want to be a badass you got
to learn to fight with a stick
back to the future
there's nothing now but will someday be
a great school
groga will be its first student
amazing
every word of what you just said
was wrong
angela will you marry scott
there's no wrong time to rock
i'm not wearing hockey pads
hello i'm epic boys guy and welcome to
jackass see you next week same on his
time same honest channel